the movie opens up as a middle-aged man
named Mark wakes up early in the morning
and starts freshening up strangely he
notices that the water supply and
electricity in his apartments are out
despite this Mark somehow gets ready for
work but as he is about to leave he
finds the main door firmly locked at the
same time he also loses his phone
network when he tries opening the door
he notices that it has been shot with a
sealant from outside distraught Mark
goes to the window to get some fresh air
but surprisingly even this is sealed
shut right then he sees other people in
the opposite building banging on their
windows for help he also notices a group
of people wearing hazmat suits and
roaming around the neighborhood ignoring
all of this Marco grabs his hammer and
tries to break the door open but ends up
hurting himself badly just then someone
from the other side of Mark's room
breaks the wall and enters his apartment
a hot-tempered boy Sergey and his little
brother Nico bar Jin Sergey immediately
goes to check on the windows but finds
out that Mark is also stuck in the same
situation is ham soon a next-door couple
Sally and Aiden also come through the
hole in the wall it appears as if
someone has locked the entire floor from
outside Aiden being a government officer
is scared about the situation and
predicts that something bad is going to
happen he desperately tries calling for
help but to no avail meanwhile the
intercom of the apartment rings and a
voice informs them to remain calm while
the medical staff is trying to take
control of the situation this worries
the already terrified group even more
later Sally being a nurse treats Mark's
wounded hand and puts some stitches on
it as the two engage in small talk Mark
suddenly remembers his elderly neighbor
Enid wasting no time he orders Sergey to
break down the wall to her apartment and
Ventures inside he finds her lying on
the floor but luckily Enid is just
sleeping in the next scene the entire
group stands by the window to find out
what's actually happening they noticed
the Hazmat suit wearing workers building
temporary medical tents in the
neighborhood meanwhile the intercom
Rings again and this time the voice
suggests everyone stay indoors as there
has been a noxious gas leak however
Aiden does not buy it he believes that
the authorities are trying to hide
something serious from them Mark also
spots a couple of medical workers
spraying disinfectants in the building
and escorting some Infected people to
their Camp suddenly when a man tries to
set himself free and run away he gets
shot by a sniper this shocks everyone
looking from their Windows shortly after
the Hazmat Waring employees start
barging inside nearby apartments when
the residents don't comply with the
protocols they are dragged outside
witnessing this Mark and the group
realize that the medical staff can
arrive at their apartment anytime hence
they start brainstorming ideas to break
the door and Escape after some time
deliberating about a possible solution
Mark remembers that he has some
corrosive chemicals in his apartment
that could be used to melt the sealant
and ultimately open the door the group
immediately starts searching for the
chemicals once they find them Mark mixes
them and creates a mixture he then pours
it on the bottom of the main door and
surprisingly the plan works Mark is
goddamn Eisenberg the sealant is
instantly loosened and after the group
pushes the door with all their might it
finally opens following this the group
starts formulating a plan so that they
can reach safety without being caught
one thing's for sure they have to be
aware of the snipers hiding at the top
of the building while they are
discussing the countermeasures Enid
realizes that Nico has gone missing as a
result everyone abandons the plan and
starts looking for the boy meanwhile a
terrified Nico has crawled down through
the air vent he reaches another floor
and notices a couple of Hazmat wearing
staff trying to convince a woman to come
with them they even inject her with a
sedative but suddenly the woman starts
coughing profusely and Falls unconscious
it appears as if the air has been
plagued with something deadly meanwhile
Mark finally finds Nico and throws a
makeshift rope to pull him out of the
vent but before the boy can grab it the
Hazmat wearing staff spot him and pull
him away fearing for his brother's life
Sergey grabs a baseball bat and runs
downstairs while Mark fall is closely
behind soon the two approach the Hazmat
guys and an enraged Sergey lashes out at
one of them the man dies on the spot and
after this Sergey grabs the other staff
member and forcefully takes her to their
apartment Sally goes through her
belongings and finds a couple of smoke
grenades this makes her suspect that
there is something wrong with whatever
is going around Mark tries to
interrogate the female staff but Sergey
drags her to the window and displays her
to the other people with the note I've
got one after tying the girl up Mark
speaks with her gently and asks her what
is going on the girl introduces herself
as Hazel Hazel the Hazmat wearer and
informs the group that they're there to
help hearing this Mark tries to remove
her protective hazmat suit but she gets
scared and shrugs him away this
convinces Mark that their place has been
infected with some sort of virus he then
threatens her to reveal everything and
now with their life on the line Hazel
finally starts speaking she reveals that
the entire area has been plagued with a
deadly virus that can kill people within
hours the symptoms include vigorous
coughing difficulty in breathing and
even blindness although the scientists
have been working tirelessly to find a
cure nothing conclusive has been found
Mark inquires as to why all the
communication systems have been shut
down to which Hazel responds that the
government doesn't want the general
public to know about the virus after all
when they found out about kovid they
bought a bunch of toilet paper and
stupid [ __ ] like that the more people
panic the more difficult it will be to
contain the virus she also reveals that
the people in the room have a 50 50
chance of Contracting the virus hearing
all this Sergey once again becomes angry
he quickly grabs a knife and tears out
her protective clothing this terrifies
Hazel so she reaches out to her pocket
and takes out an injection but before
she can use it Sergey snatches it from
her hand and keeps it with himself as
everyone looks at her in disbelief Hazel
reveals that the vaccine is still in its
testing phase and there's no assurance
that it will work hence the best thing
to do right now is to stay indoors until
the authorities take care of the
situation at night while the whole group
is discussing the measures to get out of
the place Hazel sneaks her hand from the
Ziploc and tries to escape but before
she can reach the door Sergey pins her
to the ground and starts beating her
Mark tries to stop him but ends up
facing the wrath of Sergey the commotion
finally stops when Sergey inadvertently
slaps Nico and makes him cry later the
group notices an angry mob of people
marching towards their building it
appears as if they also want to confront
Hazel to learn about the present
condition by this time all the other
Hazmat wearing staff have either been
killed or chased away scared Hazel Tells
the group to keep out the mob at all
costs as they might have been infected
with the virus this alarms the group and
they quickly block the entrance with a
heavy object soon the mob also arrives
and starts banging on the door Sally
goes near the door and tries to calm
them down but instead gets hit in the
neck by a broken piece of glass with
time running out Sergey throws the smoke
bomb at the angry people and drags Sally
to their apartment sadly it is already
too late and Sally has lost a lot of
blood even though Hazel tries her best
to say save her she is unable to this
devastates everyone especially Aiden who
breaks down and goes to the other room
in the following scene after the group
wraps Sally's Body with a piece of cloth
they search for Aiden but cannot find
him anywhere it turns out that he has
already escaped from the apartment
wearing Hazel's hazmat suit when he
reaches outside the other residents
mistake him for medical staff and
immediately surround him what did he
think was going to happen they harass
him for vaccines and start beating him
up just then the sniper fires a warning
shot prompting everyone except for Aiden
to run away from the place sadly despite
Aiden wearing a hazmat suit he is
identified as an infected patient and
shot to death that was the worst plan
I've ever seen in a pandemic movie
elsewhere Sergey goes to check out the
entrance and notices a group of
residents rushing towards them he asks
his remaining group to move out of the
room as soon as possible however Mark
does not want to leave Hazel alone so he
tries to untie her but before he can do
so an enraged Sergey knocks him out with
a baseball bat this leaves Hazel in a
precarious situation with nowhere to
hide after some time Mark regains
Consciousness and rushes to search for
Nico and the others when he peers
through the window he notices two Hazmat
guys preparing to release poisonous gas
around the building soon he finds his
group and immediately attacks Sergey for
knocking him out earlier he is about to
choke him to death but Enid intervenes
and calms him down just then the
poisonous gas is released everywhere
prompting the group to rush to the roof
on their way Mark notices the dead body
of Hazel and becomes sad meanwhile a
surviving resident from the building
approaches Sergey for help but is
brutally beaten up by the hot tempered
brat he keeps on beating the man until
other residents swarm him and hold him
captive Sergey looks to Mark and screams
for help but the latter can do nothing
other than close the door and continue
their way to the rooftop after a bit of
a struggle Mark finally leads Enid and
Nico to the rooftop since it is the
first time in days that they are
breathing fresh air they decide to sleep
here it's not like poisonous gas is
rising towards them or anything the
following morning Mark wakes up and
starts getting ready to escape from the
building however when he tries waking
the old Enid up she doesn't budge it
turns out that she passed away in her
sleep now with only little Nico left by
his side Mark wants to protect him at
all costs he tells the boy to close his
eyes for as long as he can and pretend
as if he is playing a game then he
carries Nico on his back and brings him
downstairs on the way Mark comes across
a lot of dead bodies and becomes
distraught yet he still carries on his
determination finally pays off as the
duo successfully escapes the building
Mark looks around for help but no one is
there even the contamination camps have
been deserted suddenly he hears an
announcement going around suggesting
that people stay indoors if anyone other
than medical personnel is seen they will
be apprehended as a result Mark puts on
a hazmat suit and proceeds to get out of
the area with Nico let's hope this works
out better than it did for Aiden
unfortunately just after a few minutes
they are confronted by a man from the
opposite building who mistakes my Mark
for one of the medical staff he mentions
that his wife died because of the virus
and that the authorities have taken his
daughter away he then grabs Nico and
points a sharp piece of glass at him
Mark tries his best to make the man
understand that he too is a civilian but
his efforts are futile these hazmat
suits are bad ideas just then Nico gets
away from the man but Mark is not so
lucky he is stabbed in the stomach and
fatally wounded distraught Nico helps
mark up and does the two walk away
slowly the assailant realizes his
mistake after a while they reach a
nearby park and Mark sits on a swing he
then gives Nico his cell phone and
instructs him to make a call as soon as
he gets Service Little Nico oblivious
that his only friend is dying tries to
get him up but Mark pretends that he is
just tired he tells Nico that he will
join him shortly after taking a nap the
little boy believes it and continues on
his way while Mark finally succumbs to
his injuries in the last scene Nico is
captured by a couple of Hazmat wearing
staff who inject him with a sedative
when he opens his eyes he finds himself
with other children his age one of the
Hazmat wearing staff approaches him and
assures him that everything is going to
be fine the movie ends as Nico operates
his cell phone and contemplates whether
to make a call or not the moral of
today's story is to never put on a
hazmat suit
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching